ZEKE LUNDNER: One
of the things that
spread the Camp Fire
through Paradise
was all the spot fires.
All those little baby trees
are what carries the fire up
into the crowns, and up in the
crowns, when wind's blowing,
that's how you get the
one-mile to two-mile spots.
What we want to do in
here with our burn is,
we want to get it hot enough
to kill all these little baby
green trees.
People's fear of fire is
preventing us from putting fire
on the ground here
in a good way,
in a way that will make the
people who live out here safer.
But fire is not the enemy.
ZEKE LUNDER: We're
at like 58 and--
58 and 43.
DANNY DAVIS: Yep.
I'm there.
59 and 43.
ZEKE LUNDER: OK.
Danny's people have been burning
here for thousands of years,
and there's still
forest, you know--
Well, in Hoopa, we actually
do a lot of prescribed burns
in a lot of our village sites.
We don't want to kill all the
trees and scorch the land.
You just want to manage
how many trees are growing.
So we've been doing
it for centuries.
ZEKE LUNDNER: The whole thing
about living in the woods
is figuring out a balance.
We like to think that
we can control nature.
Fire doesn't care what we
think, and whether it's
the railroad or arson or PG&E or
lightning, we will have fires.
There's nothing we can do
to keep that from happening.